The end of the initial training of the 17th class of non-commissioned officers,
including 54 resistance fighters,
11 students under the air force,deux-cent-quarante-neuf non-commissioned
officers of the 17th class of the national school
of active non-commissioned officers,
including two hundred and forty Nigerians,
and 9 of the friendly countries,
namely Burkina Faso,
Congo,
Guinea, Mali,
Chad and Togo.
Dear students,
you will soon be introduced to the national flag.
This flag symbolizes the values of the Republic,
value of fraternity,
value of work and value of progress.
These values are rooted in our traditions,
they are part of our blood and must be the compass of all citizens.
Minister of National Defence Harry draws out,
on behalf of the Chairman of the National
Council for the Safeguarding of the Fatherland,
Chief of State,
Supreme Chief of Army,
Command Generals Abdou Rahman tchani,
his deep gratitude for this patriotic impetus for the present ceremony and
the culmination of considerable collective work after 5 months of hard work,
thanks to the commitment of your supervisors and instructors,
you have acquired the reflexes and skills of a good fighter.
I congratulate you for your resolute choice to serve your dear homeland
by force of arms and to accept the risks associated with this noble choice,
the defense of the national territory and the security of our populations.
Once you have completed this stage of initial training,
you will be even more solicited in the coming months and
will resume your curriculum at this prestigious school.
The meaning of your commitment will be put.
Once you have had proof,
you must show courage,
integrity and discernment like your elders who fight day
and night in the various theaters of internal operations.
This is followed by a brace break for sub-official students,
the 17th class named H by a leader Adam onoma or somela for
overall movements and 1 military parade everywhere defends us in peace.
I said it,
I forgot it there as I was told the Guinean as we already are.